the river sane is a centerpiece of the
Paris Olympics next year the opening
ceremony will float down here and it'll
be used for swimming but a test event
the Open Water Swimming World Cup has
been canceled because the water isn't
clean enough
the scene is used as an overflow for
sewers when there's heavy rain and in
Paris it's been raining all week large
tanks to store excess storm water aren't
ready but should be in place for the
Olympics
as we had a weekend hysterical week on a
rain point of view the city of is
five-time wet the City of Paris ever
on that in that period of the year so
those water tank would have made the
difference and unfortunately since they
were not open this year but we see now
the difference we're not that far
probably tomorrow the water test will be
perfect
Olympic organizers say in recent weeks
tests of the water quality in the same
show it's regularly been clean enough to
swim in
there are Triathlon and paratriathlon
test events here in 10 days time if the
water is clean enough for that the
organizers need drier weather which
helpfully is in the forecast
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Paris
foreign